okay yeah thanks very much on the top
the screen on mine the chat is disabled
and chair very useful if you want
somebody outside the meeting or just
make a comment yeah the thing is that we
shouldn't really be making comments
outside of the meeting okay thanks Rose
is the other planning officer staying in
the waiting room to be admitted right
away no we have we have Kelly and after
in the meeting and as we did previously
I've said suggested to them that they
should be here for the introductions and
then they commute and turn their video
off until we get to their items I'm
using the first item yes we have a kelly
green hill in the waiting room now
logged in twice yeah this is gone I
think should I be gone too actually I
think she must have just accidentally
had it with her internal something yes
not yet and he's taking a second oh wait
there it is okay yeah I can see us now
okay so
we can start the meeting now we're um
realize okay thank you
right good morning and welcome to
Timbers council's planning committee by
Mike Haynes chairman of the committee
all participants here today are taking
part remotely and we are live streaming
this meeting to YouTube please could
members confirm they are present when
their name is called Chris councillor
Janet Bradford present Chancellor Philip
Bullivant prison counselor Chris
Clarence
counselor Mary cold cloth present
councillor Hugh Cox resident counselor
Linden Goodman Bradbury present Council
on Mike Keynes present councillor Rob
Hayes councillor Jackie Hook councillor
Mike Jeffery counselor Mike Jeffery okay
counselor Richard Keeling present
counselor Avril Caswell
council Kerswell all right thanks
councillor Andrew McGregor edgy
counselor John Nutley brezel cancer
Charles not all present can also Colin
Parker present can't say Adrienne patch
present counselor John Patrick I also
John Patrick president thanks counselor
Robert Phipps
I believe he's given apologies and
councillor Martin real quickly present
thanks Martin okay thank you Chris right
please make sure all microphones are
muted when you're not speaking to avoid
any background noise levels please keep
your points short and do not interrupt
when someone is speaking you wish to
comment please raise your electronic
blue hand and wait to be called any
member who does not hear the entire
debate relating to an application is not
permitted to vote on that application
during today's meeting there will be
public participation to those who have
pre-registered to speak when it comes to
the vote the Democratic Services office
that's Chris will read out members names
would members please say if they are
voting for against or abstaining the
officers present today are Rose Eastman
who's the business manager for burning
Chris Morgan the trainee Democratic
Services Officer Harter Googler planning
officer and Kelly Grinnell planning
officer and also Paul would head legal
services and Serizawa Selway democratic
services officer ok can we move on then
to item one on the agenda please
apologies for absence please Chris
apologies from councillor Jenks and
thank you item two minutes of the
previous meeting
those have only been circulated late on
yesterday a couple of errors have been
drawn to my attention minor ones but I
think it perhaps prudent for us to leave
those minutes to be corrected and then
come back to the next committee meeting
to be agreed at that meeting so if it's
your wish then the minutes will be put
back to the next meeting everyone happy
with that can you anyone know what
you'll seem hands going up then you
wonder I'm happy my close ads and
quickly that cancer them like Jeffrey
has no joined as well okay thank you
very Ron so I wondered about the
situation so he is he
no he is on the committee I couldn't
just you know I couldn't get any sound
on my iPad thank you Mike yeah we can
hear you now so that's fine okay so this
agreed that the minutes come back to the
next meeting and we now know that
counsel Mike Jeffery is present alright
so that was item two item three is the
one that's if it's required for any
exclusion but there's nothing coming up
that would expect to require that item
four declarations of interest or any
members wish to declare on the interest
please okay nobody's indicating that
obviously if it comes up you realize it
during the course of the meeting then
you declare it then item five public
participation there are objectives and
supporters of the first two applications
and there are two supporters for the
later application for the last one three
minutes for the normal applications and
it's five minutes up to five minutes for
the major application which is the last
one what will happen for public speakers
is our
invite them to join the meeting and once
we know that they are in the meeting
with us I'll hand over to the planning
officer to begin the presentation before
I ask the public speakers to give their
input right so that's item 5 item 6 is
the list of the planning applications so
we go straight on then to the first one
which is item 7
Bobby Tracey and can I then ask that you
can confirm before I move on that the
two public speakers are joining us in
the meeting um
I think we have them both till now Chris
obviously yeah in which case can I hand
over to Rose Eastman to take us through
the presentation first means before the
lens of the public because their
speeches thank you very much chair and I
will try and say my screen so that you
can see our presentation on this one if
you can confirm that you can see that
for me please I can see that yes okay
great so the application that we've got
is an application to change the use of
Brian Harris yard it's known as on
possibly Road in Bowie chasey and the
authorized use at the site at the moment
is a general industrial B to commercial
vehicle repairers youth and the
application looks to introduce a range
of other B Class employment uses at the
site and it is retrospective and the
change has has largely already happened
and youth Class B 1 covers uses that are
generally accepted within within a
residential area office research and
development and light industrial uses B
2 is general industrial and then B 8 is
a storage and warehousing use and then
we've got the ancillary use for electric
motor bike test facilities with some
wholesale distribution attached and the
site is in pottery Road
it's a long-established employment sites
and the Tory Road area is identified
within our strategic policies in the
local plan as an area where it's
important to try and retain the mix of
uses it's a mixed residential and
employment area and possibly road is the
road that the house of marbles is on and
interests in case you're not sure
whereabouts in body Tracy we are the
site has
number of buildings on it and large
areas of hard standing and open areas
but actually it's quite discrete from
the road frontage you can't really see
into the sites and the buildings are of
some age it's a long-standing employment
site and this is looking to regulate
rise and tidy up the uses that are on
site at the moment and we have had one
additional objection received since we
published the update sheet and we've
also had confirm had details of a
previous refusal at this site drawn to
our attention and which was misfiled on
a different property reference number so
that one wasn't covered in our report so
apologies for that that refusal is from
17 years ago which obviously predates
our current local plan and also predates
the national guidance that we've got in
terms the national plan and policy
framework their planning practice
guidance and also other technical
documentation such as manual for streets
so there is no objection from Devon
County highways and with the application
of conditions there is no objection from
our environmental health team or any
other of our statutory constantly so the
recommendation that is with you now is
that permission should be granted
subject to four conditions as details in
the offices report I think at the moment
that's all that I've got today so thank
you very much
Thank You rose okay right so if I can
invite the first speaker please that's
call Intel if you could switch on and
start your three minutes please
can can you hear me I can't I said calm
yeah I can't get their picture of
business right don't worry
carry on speaking don't okay all right
thank you Brian Harris yard trustees
applied under CT lighting for change of
use CT lighting has now ceased trading
so can an application be put forward
when they no longer exist
Castle a Gribble and myself met owners
of coots group to own CT lighting
we asked him who owned Bay bite as they
are a problem and the answered it was
nothing to do with them it now
transpires toots coots are the parent
company of baby bites they do mo tease
and repair road and scramble motorbikes
which are revved up frequently driven
onto the site and ridden on pottery road
cording noise and air pollution coot
scoots are applying for electric
scooters and not road and scrambler buys
the latest application is by Brian
Harris yard trustees who are applying
for the whole site in 2004 Brian Harris
applied for the use of parking of eight
lorries this was refused by team beach
planning document 23rd of february 2004
as the Hawley size' ceased to operate
and change of use from haulage and truck
repairs to commercial vehicle repairs in
March 2002 the refused reason for
refusal and I quote the introduction of
further commercial use involving the
movement of H TVs in this predominantly
residential area would cause undue
detriment to the character of the area
and the amenity of the residence
both adjacent to and opposite the site
in pottery Road and would be likely to
result in additional dangers to all
users of the road Bryn Jones Jones uses
the yard constantly active hours as do a
Bri commercial
and Bay bikes we and our neighbors were
woken up at 4:20 a.m. only some weeks
ago by Laurie's loading and leaving the
site collectively they are working from
approximately 4:00 a.m. to 10:00 p.m.
often seven days a week outside
permitted times shown on teamrees
document 4th of March 2002 we have
complained to the enforcement officer
officers continually since April 2019
with photos and diary of requested were
sent to the enforcement department no
enforcement of the working hours and the
use of the yard set out in the accepted
condition has been being forced why over
40 of the householders in the area which
include new Park have also objected the
enforcement officers have done nothing
about this in 15 months the whole site
needs to be investigated and then
enforced every commercial shoot at all
Tanith and grinders outside recently
repairing a boat engine revving up over
a two-day period lorries have been left
with engines running alongside the fence
and infused into Gardens caught in air
pollution and noise 15 years ago we
worked on it was ready danger by a
solicitor's from leaking coolant thank
you mister tell the minutes is up
think of how much if I could now ask the
supporter to speak for 3 minutes please
that's Charles White way please I in the
giving yes ok
Trevor job yeah hello who is it it's
Trevor white boy oh ok 3 minutes we'll
start when you start me ok thank you my
name you come on white like you've won
by them sand miners and my great uncle
Sidney Jerry Harris
purchased the site in the 1950
previously in the 1920
The Arbors user the transport site
happens around 2001 employing a tektite
around 70 workers when my uncle Brian
Harris closed chapter 20 company he
always been home for a number of spore
this is the main one being buddy
commercial vehicle repair when uncle
Brian died in Mikey 2012 despite his
left in a trust with my brother Phillip
and I the trust his lung body system is
fully when buddy commercials left there
was nobody on sites and Molotov it and
he fell into disrepair we believe the
previous tenant disappearance the
solicitors attempt to contact all the
tenants proved somewhat unsuccessful
therefore the spikelets listener met in
January 2019 I saw my warehouse in do
neither
I had some remaining stock the house I
look for suitable sites in the area the
choice was surprisingly limited and
apparently this is still the case
so I endeavored to use the main
warehouse on this side - how's my
leftover stock a lot of work requiring
tidying the site and making the main
shed weatherproof after clearing many
tons of rubbish and disposing of it a
chip in the art elated tidier and
quieter I trimmed the hedges to make
entry and exits and a slight safer some
of the structures water left in the
precarious state saw remove these two
during this time I was / King was
planning that the existing planning
permission if not suitable for my
intended use
therefore I would be to apply for the
Commission mainly V 1 V 2 and V a under
advisement from team breeze we had a
sauna contamination survey carried out
by Red Rock field geotechnical this
showed that the site was suitable for
employment news as it has been for more
than 100 years another site is not
employed the 70 or so people exceed the
current number on the whole site
employed is 15 this included John popper
a lot and down buildings which are owned
with the land they occupied by the
owners of those companies they did not
farm for part of this application at
present we employed for local people we
were asked to supply a parking plan and
inform numbers of employees Devon County
Council highway as we were flying for
b.a.p 102 they made two visits and
calculated the impact on traffic in air
for instance they instructed us to
increase the potential parking capacity
by one truck for b12 cars and two trucks
for vetoes and one truck and one car for
VA use this now gives a total of 13
cards and for truck allocation an
increase of four
but since we talked we received an email
on the 15th of May 2020 said that their
findings showed no impact on the network
would result under them we're planning
the new business in the what in the hole
is in the wholesale supply of worldly
road-legal electric moped scooters
distributors around the country come
come we hold upon the 120 units at any
one time sales are made online and we
have a test area for people to thrive
you know they are somewhat different
additional mobile they are silent they
make no noise they have zero emissions
and they are cheap to run very
environmentally friendly they are mostly
delivered by electric band throughout
the UK
thank you thank you
and before we move on to members can I
ask rose I mean clearly there are some
issues raised there about enforcement of
the ongoing problem this bid which I
imagine has led to this application
coming in because of the visits to the
site because your comment on the
enforcement situation as it currently
stands and yeah absolutely
okay you're right and the application
has arisen as a consequence of
discussions that have taken place with
this support and with the applicant team
and we in light of the potential lesser
impact from a b1 b2 and b8 use at this
site compared to the authorized be to
use at the site benefits from at the
moment we would have encouraged an
application and and we are it's very
highly unlikely that whilst there is an
application under consideration that we
would take enforcement action against
the site so that's why we haven't taken
any action if this application is
approved today and then we would
consider taking enforcement action if
the conditions on the permission were
not granted and the hours of working
that has been described today's just do
sound unacceptable even in a mixed use
of area like this likewise if Planning
Commission is refused today then there
will be a need for us to consider
whether or not there is merit in us
taking enforcement action
there as well so there has been liaison
and dialogue between my enforcement team
and the applicant which is why we've got
the application the application that
we've got and the controls that we've
put on that with the input from our
environmental health team we consider
would give us an enforceable framework
for us to be able to manage this site
into the future so that it can operate
as a successful employment location in
this important mixed use passive body JT
thank you right can I turn now then to
the ward member who asked for this to
come to committee and council occurs
well thank you chairman hmm
I brought this planning application to
today's meeting as it is not as
straightforward as it may seem at first
glance the town council objected
objected to it on many levels as on the
grounds of highway safety increased
traffic generation noise distribution
and air pollution also the concern of
increased working hours we've had nearly
4 to 40 letters of objection from local
residents we have to put up with the
daily noise and inconvenience which this
site generates for many years and it's
getting worse you can see the reputation
representations from the public in
paragraph 6 of your agenda they have
complained to steve hobbs our
enforcement officer time and time again
but nothing seems to get done we are
well aware that this area of Bobby
Tracey is a mixture of residential and
industrial units and on the whole it
works well with the majority of
businesses being respectful of the
residents and the residents feel
respectful of the businesses in fact
when we Tracie's our hold relies on
those small businesses for growth and
prosperity however this particular site
floats the original recognize
Commission's on a daily basis in fact
I was talking to recently they said they
had on more than one occasion being
woken up in the early hours of the
morning with HTV traffic movements from
this site in paragraph two
item three it states that working arts
should be a Monday to Friday 8:00 to
6:00 and 8:00 to 1:00 on Saturdays
it then goes on to say that no works
likely to give rise to significant
levels of noise outside of these times
should occur on Sundays and bank
holidays however how can you control
this when you haven't been able to in
the past
no it must stay with no workings at all
on Saturday afternoon Sunday's and bank
holidays in paragraph three point three
we are told the applicant seeks
retrospective planning permission for a
change of use once again owners of sites
just carry on and expect planning
permissions to come later
whereas this should be done the other
way around the electric moped business
appears to be a good business and as
bummy Tracy and team 'bridge have
declared a climate emergency these are
the kind of businesses which we would
like to promote but we must get the rest
of the site to conform first otherwise
the owners of the site will just flout
the rules forevermore
pottery Road has a 30 mile an hour speed
limit and there are cars parked both
sides of its Road every day the idea
that more large HGV vehicles will be
encouraged to you this to our mind is
ludicrous once again who will monitor
the extra vehicles coming to him from
this site it's all very well having the
guidance from Democratic highways but
that's all it is guidance in your report
paragraph 3.4 planning history you state
all the permissions this site has been
given over the years but you failed to
disclose that in 2004
planning permission was refused to the
Lanza Park
8ht be lorries in this predominantly
residential area as it would cause undue
detriment to the character of the area
and the amenity of the residents both
adjacent to and opposite the citing
pottery Road and would be likely to
result in additional Jayne danger to all
users of the road since then the area
has become even more busy and the risks
of danger to residents and visitors far
greater
we must not exacerbate the situation
anymore also the noise which these
vehicles make in a built-up area is
considerable and the air pollution to
the adjoining properties when the
vehicles are idling in the yard is such
that residents cannot sit out and enjoy
their own gardens in paragraph 3.10 it
states that there is dust fumes and
other forms of pollution or nuisance
which arrives from the proposed
development we cannot be expected in
this time of climate emergency to
condone these proposals paragraph 3.11
states that team bridge district council
environment environmental health
department have commented with regard to
the noise impacts due to the close
proximity of residential dwellings to
the Brian Harris yard as of course they
have received many complaints and have
recommended Monday to Friday and
Saturday morning working with no
Sunday's or bank holidays we then see
that the African agent then stated in an
email on February the 25th 2020 that
they no longer wished for the increase
of hours but then goes on to say that
these uses are unlikely to be noisy and
could be accommodated with the condition
detailed in the recommendation therefore
I say to you this statement is quite
ambiguous and should just say once and
for all the
there will be no working on Saturday
afternoons Sundays and bank holidays .
in paragraph 3.14 we note the TDC a bio
bio diversity officer includes
regulations for external lighting and we
thank you for that
in paragraph 3.2 to our officers have
gained that this application is
considered to be acceptable and does not
adversely affect neighboring properties
well for all the reasons I have stated
in my report it clearly does affect
neighboring properties and their
residents and has done for a very long
time if we grant this application in its
present form
we are only conduct compounding the
problems which already exists therefore
I propose that we refuse this
application until we can find a workable
solution Brian Harris yard trustees and
the residents of pottery Road finally
it's worth noting that the whole of the
Brian Harris yard is for sale through an
Exeter commercial agent Thank You Janice
alright thank you I think that last
point is a planning matter I ask perhaps
noise to come back on some of the issues
that have been raised clearly I'm sure
members share my concern about the
ongoing problems that have been
experienced there with the the noise but
we I mean the difficulty is going to be
the level of noise outside of those
hours and sort of how that gets
determined I don't think we can go
personally down the route of of having
no working outside of those hours and in
normal circumstances of course that I
would have seen this as being an ideal
place for improving employment because
it is in close proximity and so to
residential and people are able to
travel there more sustainably than other
applications we've seen recently but I'm
also familiar with the problem
industrial sites and proximity to
residential areas have because I've got
one in my own world anyway Ross did you
want to comment plays on those
enforcement issues and and the
conditions that are being proposed yeah
sure I think the first point to make
here is that if Planning Commission were
refused for this site then it would
still benefit from a b2 consent that's a
general industrial consents and whilst
it was used as a commercial vehicle
repair is in the past there are a range
of other b2 general industrial uses that
could be acceptable at this site as well
so the introduction of a mix of uses
here in theory and compared to the
full-back position should lead to an
improvement at the site and what we've
got in the condition that we've proposed
and does follow the recommendation that
we have from our environmental health
officer so if we were looking to approve
and this scheme but with a different
condition then that would be tricky for
us to justify and I think that it must
be right to say that the quiet
activities and should be allowed to
carry on outside at those times and
notwithstanding that that can be
difficult to enforce and I've mentioned
previously that we wouldn't take
enforcement action whilst we've got the
application in but that doesn't mean
that we won't take enforcement action
moving forward if the site continues to
cause problems and I would agree that
heartless or in the morning is not an
acceptable time for works to start at
the site so our you know absolutely the
residents have my support on that and so
I think that the the fallback position
is a really important thing that we need
to take into account and it is true that
the working hours did get adjusted
during the life of the permission so
that has changed and I've highlighted
previously while I don't think that the
refused permission from 2004 is relevant
here we've got a different set of
circumstances and we've got no objection
from our highways advisors and
colleagues they're within a different
policy policy world now and including
with a very clear and support in our our
strategic policies for employment
development in the pottery Road area and
just the clarity and councillor purple
suggested that paragraph 310 we've said
the proposal will be noisy and dusty we
haven't we've said that that our policy
framework outlines that those things
need to be taken into account
mmm excuse me and it's in taking those
things into account that we consider
that there is no overarching conflict
with policy here thank you okay thank
you so nobody else indicating to speak
yeah I mean the position I find myself
in is that I can entirely sympathize
with the objectors points about the
noise and the enforcement issues but I
cannot see any planning reasons for
refusing this given that it's a change
from b2 to b1 b2 and b8 and the and the
Seri generous use of the electrical
moped motorcycle use so I can't see a
reason a valid planning reason for
refusal the reason why we're here today
I think is because of the problems that
have been caused on the site by the the
uses that are causing a nuisance to
local residents I can only see a way
forward on this that it's personally my
view that it's approved as the
recommendation set out but then
enforcement action is taken by planning
and environmental health if those
conditions are breached anyone else wish
to speak I've not got any hands
indicated all right well I'll move the
recommendation as sorry I beg your
pardon I'm still not pressing right a
bigger pond right Jackie hook yeah thank
you I think my own participant hand as
well yeah I think the key fact here is
the outlined in 3.6 is the report which
has been referred to by Roz and yourself
Mike
that the site does have a current
planning permission for B to use and out
of those three uses b1 which is business
be to general industrial and v8 storage
and distribution I would suggest that
potentially be to is the the most
disruptive in a residential area and so
the addition of the other two doesn't
make it worse in the situation that
that's there it is largely as I can see
and understand the issue an issue of
enforcement rather than this change of
youth application which is potentially
at least an improvement but I do very
much sympathise with these sites I have
one in my area as well in you to have
that close juxtaposition of residential
and business industrial use does cause
trouble on occasions and so I didn't
really sympathize but the fact of the
matter is giving this permission doesn't
alter the facts of the matter of what
happens on that site and potentially
could lead to an improvement the only
thing that I was going to ask is whether
there's any opportunity to limit the
size of vehicles that visit the site if
not for the b2 use which obviously has
permission but for example for the
storage and distribution which
potentially does involve quite large
vehicles is there any means by which we
can limit the size of vehicles visiting
the site because I certainly know in my
area that it's one of the key factors
that causes concern and damage to
vehicles themselves it's very large
vehicles access in a long residential
streets aren't appropriate so is that
something we can address okay Ross it's
always really hard to try and ascribe
cause and effect and in these instances
we I've got a construction site where
I'm just down the road from where I live
at the moment and my local community has
been getting very frustrated with some
large vehicles using what they see as
the wrong construction access routes and
then apparently it turns out that
actually those vehicles weren't going to
the construction site they were going
beyond it to another site somewhere else
so and we could potentially look to put
controls on this site but because it's a
mixed user
those those lorries and vehicles could
be accessing any one of a number of
sites along this road but that don't
have those restrictions on it and so we
can't always um it's very difficult for
us to enforce and would seem to be an
unfair penalty to me for this site if
it's not also applied elsewhere and it
would be yeah very very difficult for us
to enforce a condition of that nature
and notwithstanding that I understand
the the sentiment I understand the
sentiment but it's not something I would
be comfortable enforcing on on the file
either thank you Chris plants councillor
Gramps Thank You chairman it's the issue
of noise that I find is the interesting
one the test of noise becoming a public
nuisance to residents seems to be
adopted by Dean bridge that if you're in
your own home home and the third party
makes his king uh shall we say making
noises then the test seems to be if that
person if you're in your home you cruise
shut the windows you have to turn up and
you have to turn up a little television
remember your windows are closed in
order to hear it that becomes a public
nuisance I don't know where this test is
originating from I'm waiting to hear on
this business of noise from the head of
environmental health have raised this
question with him but we don't seem to
have any teeth where with regard to
noise I maintain that we should as a
council be using a decibel meter and it
should be X amount of decibels at X
amount of distance without an
obstruction in the way decibel meters
are that I would have thought the
approved method of determining what
becomes a public nuisance or not and
without these safeguards we find a bit
we found a bit powerless to do anything
about there's the sort of issues that
you've raised with the environmental
health of teen bridge so our huge
concerns over this and whether whether
we're determining noise in the right way
and our inability
to enforce any conditions I'll leave it
at that chairman thank you thank you
councilor patch Thank You chair
I do take on board councillor hooks
comments about the existing planning
permissions for the site but I do also
take on board the objectives speech and
cancer kurz Wales points made and I was
just going to say that if policy valid
policy reasons for rejection could be
put forward I would be happy to second
council occurs wells proposal to put
this to a vote okay I don't think counts
occurs where actually did make a
proposal yet I haven't heard of any
policy reasons as yet being put forward
I beg your pardon I said that before we
grant I would suppose that we refuse
this application until we could find a
workable solution for Brian Harris yard
trustees and the resident of pottery
Road but I am adamant about the times as
well chairman that they shouldn't be
outside of normal working hours Monday
to Friday and Saturday morning thank you
are there any any policies on which to
to base that please I think that was the
question from councilor patch well only
only the ones that we as a town council
we objected on the many grounds of
highways the increased traffic the noise
distribution in our pollution and the
concern of the working hours and I
haven't got the actual policy numbers
here but those are what what we're what
we're objecting to yeah the difficulty I
have is that we don't have any Devon
County highways Authority support for
that or indeed any other evidence that's
been brought forward of the air
pollution or the noise and we're being
asked to approve times for
for opening with the when there would be
noise so I am I can't see any any
policies that actually have been put
forward there's a reason for refusing I
think that's that's where we are
chairman sometimes you've got to look
outside the box and you know we're
looking outside the box here for the
people of lovely Tracy who are finding
it very difficult to live in their own
homes and gardens their gardens so
sometimes you've just got a look that
little bit further not everything can be
done it out and taken down to planning
policy if it was these people wouldn't
be floating the rules in the first place
yeah the difficulty I have is that it's
already got permission for b2 which is
likely to be the source of existing
noise and outside of ours so I you know
I think we're obviously going to
disagree on this one I've got councillor
Bradford I think indicated speak Thank
You chair I just like to show my support
to cancel occurs like I don't think we
should be confining the problems for
residents the noise the traffic the air
pollution I don't have policy numbers
either but I just agreed that we
shouldn't make it worse for the
residents okay um thank you well I mean
the view I take is that we would improve
things for the residents I actually
approving conditions that are attached
to this and then taking enforcement in
environmental health action as would
happen at other sites and also
acknowledging that this site already has
be to use across the whole site right
what councillor Kerr as well get movie
fusible but I've not heard any one
second I've got councillor McGregor
wishing to speak
Thank You chair Malou the the
application I really genuinely can't see
a planning reason to reject but what I
will say is the supporter Trevor
outlined that part of the business and
it's outlined in the in the planning
application is to have a sweet generous
business effectively running from there
which is based around electric vehicles
which will be a lot quieter and if
that's a large and growing business then
that will take up more of the site and
reduce the amount of storage and
distribution vehicles probably to those
that are delivering it in bulk to the
site as it goes forward so are we are we
arguing the toss over potentially the
keeping the site as it is with all the
problems that occur now or taking a site
and reducing the amount of vehicle
vehicle presence within the site that
produced the pollution and the noise
according to Trevor I believe you can
not Trevor if this is correct you
mentioned it by electric vehicles is
that correct no we the public speakers
have actually finished their input so it
is just to confirm that at the point
that the electric vehicles there are two
scooters will be distributed from the
side by electric vehicles which is which
is a reduction in noise in real terms so
from my perspective I really can't see a
planning reason to reject at this stage
thank you has anyone I mean if anyone's
coming up with a policy reasons to
support council occurs Wells wish to
proposal refusal otherwise in order to
give us a clear thing to move forward
there's not been a second yet I would
move the prove allows set out and invite
somebody that's just spoken to second
that please I'll second that
thank you who is that please it's me
Martin Wrigley Martin look out sir
Wrigley a second so it's been moved
approval as set out on the agenda and
that's been seconded so that's the
motion that is before us now nobody else
has indicated that they wish to speak in
which case
can I ask Chris please to go through a
roll call vote on this so the motion is
for approval so can you please say you
are either for against or abstain when
Chris reads out your name thank you okay
um councillor bradford against
councillor Bullivant I have to leave the
room to attend along during part of the
presentations by the objective so I
can't okay
councillor Clarence abstain comes the
cold Clough councillor Cox for sounds
like Goodman Bradbury for councillor
Haines for councillor Hayes all
councillor hook Oh
councillor Mike Jeffery counts of a
Keeling or council occurs well
councillor Caswell against councillor
McGregor or counselor nutley or
counselor Nuttall for the Parker for
councillor patch against councillor
Patrick and councillor Wrigley oh okay
okay so that's 13 in favor three against
and three abstentions
I think two reps tensions and one was
not voting okay I don't being in the
meeting so yes it counts as an
abstention as well okay thank you so I
agree in which case that is approved as
set out right can we move on then to the
next application using ttan if we could
ensure that the two public speakers are
actually with us before I invite the
officer to outline the details on this
hello good morning are we we got both
mr. singleton and not Smithers we just
have a second to make sure if we can
move
I think I move confirm that so Paul
singleton can you confirm your witness
base
yes I'm here good morning thank you it's
Bruce Robertson can you confirm your
area please Bruce might have your mute
on there's also two in though the
waiting rooms I've added them both I'm
not sure which one is correct so I might
have been an accidental double joining
mr. Roberts are you with us
I'm going to see BR that no young
indication of audio war or visual
you
you
Bruce your um your Leafs on I think if
you look at the bottom left
beautiful how's that there we go hello
good morning okay so I think we're all
here now so what happen is our last
planning officer to give us an update or
to go through the presentation rather
and then I'll invite the public speakers
to take part so can I ask part I could
go there please to take us through the
presentation Thank You chair I'm just
gonna pull up my presentation and show
my screen so this application can then
everyone see and hear me probably yeah
okay it's pretty much okay so this
applications foreign construction of a
secondary access to the trago mills
complex this is a location map showing
the whole of this site and then in red
is outlined whether we're the new axis
will be located just this southwest
corner of the site if I pull up the
aerial view that's a little bit better
and currently there is an existing axis
which is disused at the moment and gated
it's a temporary track which was used
during the construction of some of the
parts of the complex but never has been
used as a customer and staff access this
is just a close closer up view off of
the axis so it will actually come from
railroad into the site opposite that
meeting hole it would it's been applied
for to provide a more direct access for
for customers and staff traveling from
the southwest this is the construction
details off the road so it will be hard
surface to allow traffic in both
directions and there's also soakaway
proposed to deal with any surface water
originating from from the additional
from from their development and the axis
will either be operate open only during
the operating hours off of did of the
trade owners development here's just an
extract from the traffic survey
submitted which shows their potential
the ridge that were undertaken by
customers and staff on the day that data
was collected so we're really looking at
ridge free which is the blue one that
will be mostly used which at the moment
accommodates 18 percent of of the
customers and staff entering the site
potentially are route 4 will also be
used that accommodated for customers and
it was around four percent of customers
that used those routes through to drawn
bridges so and it can be proposed that
this traffic will be reassigned to this
new axis should it be approved and here
are just some percentages of how many
customers staff and and all ships I use
and what routes have been taken
undertaken so here we've got rich Lee
and reform which would be the kind of
main ones undertaken by customers and
staff from the new access and here's
just some pictures of how that site
currently lies so there is an existing
gated access there and staple wrote in
both directions right outside outside
the access so in terms of updates us out
in the report there is no objections
from from Devon County highways in the
meantime since the update has been
uploaded we've had six more letters of
objections raised in only issues and
we've had consultation response from
high as how is England who also
concluded that there'll be no traffic
safety implications on the strategic
road network however they've suggested
some conditions which included boundary
treatment and clamping and construction
management plan which was already been
included in the report our
recommendation is to approve the
application with delegated authority to
Audrey conditions as we're still unsure
whether the boundary treatment and
planting conditions would be necessary
in terms of the effect on the strategic
road network okay thank you
let's finish if you can return to the
normal screen
okay
so can I ask Paul singleton pleased to
have your three minutes you're on mute
mr. singleton you me now yes okay ooh
stable home road is a typical Devon
country lane with high hedges and gore
visibility it's in the main a single
carriageway it's very narrow at 2.5
meters wide in certain places it's not
suitable for anything other than
slow-moving vehicles it's frequently
used by cyclists walkers and horse
riders it's extremely difficult to pass
when two cars meet and it regularly
floods it's used recreationally because
it's considered safe place to exercise
and enjoy nature the t-junction with
libertine is on a blind band with no
pavements the t-junction is heavily
parked up with parents cars from
blackboard school resulting in car doors
opening young children in the road and
parents with buggies in the road the
traffic survey that's used in this
application is out of date as it doesn't
it refers to 9:30 2014 and it doesn't
take account of the growth in pupil
numbers and development of blackboard
school the t-junction libitum is also
the school bus stop for Dartmouth
College where students catch the bus
traffic turning interstate walk Hill
Road will have to navigate
schoolchildren numerous parked cars in
and around the junction with Dartmouth
I've thought more college bus at a point
where visibility is poor and there are
no pavements the proposed entrance will
inevitably lead to a road traffic road
traffic accidents with the environmental
considerations are that the a38 German
expressways objective was to stop
traffic
passing through villages and the traigo
entrance flaps this object is very
clearly the road through beakington
village will become heavily used by
traffic leaving the a38 have the good
standing to change route for traigo and
stable the road making turn already
suffers speeding traffic racing through
the village the proposal will exacerbate
this issue the proposed traigo entrance
will turn the rural village of
Binghamton into a service road there
will be increased noise pollution and a
degradation of air quality for the
villages of Liberty high volumes of
traffic passing through big engine will
include hdvs
and delivery vehicles it's a planning
application does not respect the rural
way of life and atmosphere and character
on the note about planning notices the
residents will make it clear that nobody
is aware of any planning notices having
been posted in little village baking tin
village all the vicinity of staple the
road residents became aware of this
application via text message from
concerned neighbor lack of planning
notices and the effect of Kovach 19
lockdown has impeded the parents of
Blackpool's share that's time I go tiny
sentence race its impeded the parents of
Blackpool school raising their comments
or concerns and without planning
planning notices being posted this
application was received over 30 formal
objections from residents
thank you thank you okay moving on to
support events of mr. Bruce Robinson
good morning time is tight I'll keep
this brief our application to provide
the Trager complex with a sacrament
secondary access is to future-proof the
business and the 600-plus jobs of those
engaged directly at the site you'll be
aware that a wel has an extent consent
for ambitious and scalable developments
of what is commonly known as the traigo
approach road that leads from the a 382
to
store of experience works on the a380 -
alone we are concerned that even
following disruptive early construction
phases there is a prospect for the
longer term ligature being applied to
our present sole means of access which
could render our enterprise unattractive
and commercially unviable members may
recall that the original entrance to
traigo was off the former 8:38 adjacent
to the then montz transport cafe and on
to staple Hill Road a route that was
temporarily approved for use during the
construction of the garden park that
opened in 2009 the stretch that will be
used if our application has your support
is at least two vehicles width rule-outs
straight and off which motorists will
turn will have turned into tray go
before the first right-hand Brend
we're indeed the road narrows thereafter
the new access is intended to
principally serve motorists traveling
eastbound from Plymouth on the west but
it will also deliver options for those
traveling from the south on the a3 8-3
the northwest of newton now that having
witnessed substantial housing
development in recent years those
amongst you living nearby in Ilsan can
perish will doubtless have noticed the
increase in traffic this last fortnight
deuteron lengthy diversion necessitated
by the a380 2's temporary closure we
have felt it too for other reasons may I
stress that this must not be compared
with with that which we are proposing as
of course the junction with staple Hill
Road is before the primary school and
above libitum per se the strago traffic
traveling from the West will not impact
on either as acknowledged by den Devon
County Council who support this
application has also acknowledged by the
County Authority the peaks of the school
and traigo do not align in any event I
would add that the drum bridge is
interchange only has finite remaining
capacity even following its recent
signalization our proposal will divert
traffic from it releasing future
capacity which I hope may facilitate
other worthy developments north and side
a 38 trunk in conclusion our desire is
simply to secure the future viability of
our business and to safeguard it against
eventualities that we unsuccessfully
endeavored to resist those concern those
concerns and objections relating to a
wel being on specifically highways and
traffic grounds in isolation thus our
pros will proposal can also deliver
community benefit in improving flow and
freeing up capacity through the drum
bridges roundabouts appears a positive
contribution in itself and I hope it may
commend itself to you for this reason to
our initial application was made several
years before this wretched pandemic
we're all enduring one of us one way or
another can I finish the sentence thank
you thank you our community and its
economy requires all possible stimuli
during what will be a long recovery and
we very much hope would wish to play our
part in that process I do hope it may
have your support thank you thank you
the patch thank you chair before I start
my speech I just referred to the
document that I emailed members of this
committee yesterday and request that
given there's lots of technical drawings
in there and in photographs if it's
necessary to enlighten the discussion if
councillors would like any of those
diagrams online the chair and the
planning officer actually have copies of
that presentation if I'm not allowed to
put them on share screen perhaps they
will if councillors request viewing of
any of the illustrations okay I'll make
a start now it's been mentioned that the
local highways authority and highways
England have neither of them objected to
this application as has been made clear
to me neither of them have carried out
an independent assessment of the
applicants traffic and highway
assessment it is not come under any deal
of rigorous scrutiny regarding some of
the claims and I will address some of
those in this talk and I believe it
actually comes down to
counselors now to scrutinize this
highways assessment given that I don't
believe it has been until now starting
with a reason set out by applicant for
the proposed second entrance there are
four of them one the long history of
congestion at drum bridge is round about
now the applicant will probably be aware
that there is a substantial upgrade to
the roundabout with in recent years
local residents I don't believe consider
it congested at all
reason number two provide greater
flexibility for customers intrusive
entrance and parking okay that that's a
that's a valid argument for is number
three better use of car parking now
states of a site I don't believe this is
a valid argument sorry I need an
internal road control in this site can
provide them with better use of their
existing car parking assets number four
planned improvements the a 382 corridor
I don't think this can be considered
about valid argument I think this is a
valid item against the opening up of
this site because what it will do is
under circumstances of works on that 88
to Corrigan or particularly a closure
traffic will be diverted by the a 383
and victim Road if the stable group
Junction is open there will be increased
traffic turning right just around a
blind Bend so of those four reasons that
set out in the highways assessment I
think only one of them really stands to
provide greater flexibility for
customers so I've got four or four
issues that I'd like to put forward on
highways safety issues wide this
proposal ought to be really sort of
questioned first is will will a new
accident black spot be created the
junction of the victim Road and stable
Hill Road so the potential traffic
impact of the Prost proposed new
entrance might be considered for two
local road junctions
firstly is this baking tin relevant
staple railroad junction but both those
junctions are each being in the
unfortunate position of being situated
behind limited visibility bands on
stretches of road with a national speed
limit of 60 miles an hour the highways
the traffic and highways assessment of
the applicant makes calculation
to assess the extent of likely cueing at
these junctions behind limited
visibility bands these calculations are
likely to underestimate the extent of
eschewing for two reasons firstly the
use of odd baseline traffic data from
2015
secondly questionable assumptions of
reassignment to the new junction of
customers from other routes to the main
entrance in a survey of 2014 and we saw
the image of the various groups to the
existing entrance and and it was
acknowledged that only one of those
entrances one of those routes rather
would reassign to do the new entrance in
fact as I also show below several of
them might reassign to that entrance
which would have an effect opportunity
coming from the Billington road end of
making more likely traffic queues at the
junction behind the blind Bend second
okay so that the the applicants traffic
and highways assessment concludes
recording that Junction the increase in
the mean maximum Jews at that Junction
will be negligible with less than one
vehicle queuing at any time on any arm
of the junction no improvements are
required to this Junction to accommodate
the reassigned traffic associated with
the proposed access but how robust and
safe are those calculations about the
safety of the staple new road junction
given that the use of 2015 traffic data
the questionable assumptions about
reassignment of traffic to the proposed
entrance and the likely traffic flows
from a new residential developments
recently opened them planned to south
and west of Newton Abba and I to Din
that Hill Park the wall road development
which has been given the green light and
the Houghton Barton development which
which might indeed access the site via
the 8383 and at stable who Road junction
question - is it likely that other
action of black spots will be made worse
and I'll refer here to the junction of
the a38 3 and picketing road which again
is behind a blind bent or
so Anna limited visibility bounds and
it's known locally as a dangerous
Junction the how the applicants highway
traffic nyway assessment states the
increase in traffic at this location as
a result of the proposed access does not
cause any capacity problems at this
Junction the increase in a mean maximum
Q that Junction will be minimal that's
their view now the assessment is similar
to similar flaws to those outlined above
in the analysis of the state of the road
junction basically the calculation has
include Oh traffic data questionable
assumptions regarding traffic
reassignment a mixture of traffic data
from the recent and likely residential
developments around new Java I just
quickly point out the fact that within
the last week there have been two
vehicle crashes at this dangerous
Junction and I have circulated
photographs of their whose two members
of this committee the second of those
crashes has actually been confirmed to
being at that site rather than further
down via 383 now if you lit specifically
at the accident report data the actual
of reticles including the applicants
report emit the most recent years data
available and use only three years of
data rather than the five years date
appropriate for a recognized dangerous
Junction I've included two anted my
illustrations two councillors a map
setting out the accidents recorded on
the on the database and note that every
three eight three junction on the map
that might be used as a cut through
between a three eight three two baking
Tehran routes of proposed entrants
recorded at least one accident in the
last five years and there are many more
accidents recorded along this route than
in the analysis presented in the
applicants report question three my
staple who wrote become a gridlock track
run I included Google Maps images to
show the traffic from the south and west
of Newton Abbot is likely to take that
the cut through that will use staple
Hill Road to approach a new entrance
that is as has been pointed out a very
narrow and Wanda Lane now there's a real
possibility of particularly given the
fact that some people on the school run
use that route as well of
Lane becoming gridlocked as well as the
potential dangers that might accrue to
users of that site I've also included it
in the illustrations to counselors a map
from the report of the applicants which
shows the a38 to works the upgrades to
the traffic corridor house important
development and stable Hill Road
providing as you're highlighted in red
that's favorable road which hasn't been
highlighted seeds in the applicants
report and it's quite clear that the
large part of that house important
development won't be on the edge of that
staple real Road and that will be the
natural access to a natural route to get
to that access question for my final
question you'll be glad to hear my quiet
country lanes and roads become
significantly more dangerous leading to
loss of amenity for walkers cyclists and
horse riders state Google Road has been
discussed above a potentially large
increasing traffic along that route will
impact Walker cyclist and horse riders
Bickleton cut throughs have also been
indicated in the accident report map
live guys deliver ton
I've presented a map showing potential
cut throughs from Bovey Tracey and
Beyond including vehicles cross and pass
blackberry primary school to conclude I
believe that the traffic and highways
assessment is a significantly flawed
document I do not believe it has been
scrutinized in a dito by local authority
offices even highways england-based a
recommendation for approval upon an
admitted acceptance at face value of the
analysis presented by the applicant IP
the consequently we have a duty to
properly scrutinize that document and to
form an opinion on questions around the
road safety risks and wider potential
highways impact of the proposal in doing
so we must judge whether what I consider
the one valid reason for the proposal
customer flexibility in accessing the
site Warren seeks acceptance or whether
it should be rejected for highway safety
issues I believe that given the
seriousness of the traffic and road
safety risks it should be rejected and I
formally make that proposal thank you so
you're proposing it be refused on
highways grounds yes
thank you a seconder yes I was like this
Ben I saw John Perry it comes up as
Rick's hand furthest so that's okay and
right before I and I've got a couple of
people wishing to speak I will ask my
daughter to come in if there are any
points arising from that that you wish
to come back on from the public speakers
or what we just heard I think in terms
of scrutinizing and the traffic
assessment so as the planning officer
and the local authority we read through
the document we've had the relevant
consul T so highways England and Devon
County Council look at it on our behalf
from a Highway Safety and highways air
impact point of view they have come back
to us with with no objections and hence
why we move with it with the
recommendation for approval as they are
the kind of responsible body in their
highways matters so we've used their
expertise in our recommendation Thank
You Ozzy wanted to add before what
before Ross comes in perhaps I could
just interject there highways England I
would have thought would only be
concerned about the impact on
particularly on the the a 38 and given
that it potentially takes a bit of
traffic off that there at one point I
don't think they are going to
particularly be concerned it's the Devon
County Council position which clearly
they they don't see an objection to it
so that's that's the difficulty we would
have is having highway support if that
were the reason for refusal was Thank
You Terry yes you're absolutely right
and in the absence of any support from
our technical consul to you on this
point I am defending a decision would be
difficult
and the county highway officer afield
briefly as a partner in the developments
that our plan for Neeson Abbott are
aware of the Hatton Barton's puzzles
including the new link road and are
aware of the volume of traffic that is
likely to be moving around the Newton
Abbot area over the next few years and
they have even taken that into account
they have concluded that there are no
highway capacity or highway safety
reasons for refusal and and they have
contented themselves that the data
included in the highway assessment is
satisfactory as a basis for making that
decision and I understand and the point
that council Apache is making about you
know why does the applicant want to do
this and you know that's that's sort of
valid background and reasoning to the
proposal but the key issue here is is
less whether or not we we agree that
choice is or isn't a good reason to have
this proposal it's whether or not there
are any planning reasons for refusal now
that the application has been made and
so county and highways England don't
have any concerns that the data used and
I agree that and highways England's
concern would be about impact on drum
bridges and impact on the strategic road
network but equally if they thought
there was something wrong with the data
that had been used they would be they
would have highlighted that and and the
assessment that's been undertaken on my
reading of it is one that's included
assumptions that all all trips would be
diverted onto this route so the
assessment has been stress test tested
by looking at a higher level of trips
being diverted onto this alternative
access than would actually likely be
realized and just as a consequence of
customer choice I know lots of people
who don't like driving on single lane
roads so they would continue to use the
manger on bridges access and so you know
the proposals have been stressed tested
in both terms of highway capacity and
highway safety and there's been found to
be no reason for refusal there by our
technical council TS and thank you thank
you
I've got will be quite people are
indicated to speak so what counseling
not me first means Thank You chairman
yes I aku capture patches comments I
think there's not many of us and don't
go to tribal Mills to do shopping by
myself bought large items there and
myself but in saying that I do not think
personally that secondary road in to try
go without any impact whatsoever on
Tragos trade or or anything in the
future my concern as being a board
member of the adjacent water picking
t'en is the actual increase along that
road of traffic etc and as Chancellor of
bench mentioned and I have a friend
who's on the fire service of Ashburton
they've attended two accidents on that
junction of baking Tintin and the
Ashburton Road in the night in 24 hours
on Friday
there has been fatalities there before
just a little further day but the
problem is there the traffic coming from
that road it's a sixty mile road you
around that bend on to that Junction and
that's what the reason of the action
bond things my also concern is Topsy for
the Blackpool children that go to the
school there maybe not so bad probably
first thing in the mornings but in the
afternoons at the busy time when they
flexing their children is the increase
in traffic on that section to say I've
got great fears of that and I personally
could not support this as it in present
state thank you Thank You councillor
McGregor
Thank You chair I wanted to raise a
couple of points around the the highways
assessment and and also perhaps maybe
revisit with Arthur one of the slides
that was put up in terms of 3.18 on the
report it says there be no collisions at
Junction Victor and staple Hill and no
collisions local area involving
pedestrians in the period between the
1st of January 2014 and the 31st of
December 2018 that's all well and good
bearing in mind that that road is not
being used currently for that particular
access to two trago mills so you know
basing basing a report on on the fact
that there's no current accidents it
seems a little bit strained then that we
would say you know that route the issues
for there by pedestrians and horses and
cyclists we're certainly gonna start
presenting that a lot of traffic I take
the point about it having been used as a
an access during construction but the
access during construction at that time
there was lots of signs lots of cones
people were aware that construction
traffic was going in and out there was I
think there might have even been a
reduced speed restriction on that on the
road there so all of that taken into
account really the the installation of a
route from traigo onto a very probably
busy at times lane but with with
pedestrians cyclists and horses presents
a risk to the public in real terms the
the what was the other thing I was good
oh yes they've actually put up one of
the slides that they gave percentages of
route use on R 1 R 2 R 3 R 4 R 5 sorry
my connection connection is unstable it
just tells me but it doesn't actually
give us vehicle movement numbers you
know so a percentage of you know 60% of
staff using a particular route in
doesn't tell us how many staff are using
that route
so it doesn't tell us how many vehicle
movements but when you look at our r3
and r4 which were the two main routes
that would use that the percentage of
vehicles using those routes is is
actually very very small and it calls
into question both the idea that this is
a sustainable development if the
expectation is that it will have no
impact on the volume of traffic going
through and you know in real terms it it
then barely you know draws justification
Bracci putting the road in in the first
place
know it so my view that there is there
is a question mark over whether it
actually is a sustainable development
and whether or not the attitude adds any
value to the business at all in terms of
future proofing okay thank you for the
question you asked about actual numbers
I had previously asked that question
myself so I know you guys have the
figures so perhaps you could come back
and give us the figures because I
haven't got them easily to hand I'd have
to go off this screen Artur the figures
of the actual numbers please so there'd
be actual route percentage percentages
were derived from how many people were
surveyed and asked what routes they have
taken these were undertaken by the two
kind of entrances within the site and
customers and staff we're asked what
route they've taken and I believe it was
around 1500 people that we're and
surveyed each time they were surveyed so
it would be 18 percent of around 1,500 I
haven't got the exact figure here I can
no I think the conversation that asked
and I have had about this and I think
demonstrators are in the peak our trips
accessing the site that was around 110
120 peak hour trips it would be diverted
so 120 peak hour trip
on a Saturday morning is two additional
cars per minute and which is not
considered to be a significant level of
traffic or a significant increase so to
two additional trips per minute but
that's the peak and that's assuming that
that so that's the peak on a Saturday
morning and that is assuming that all
trips from that direction would be
diverted so that was the 18% figure so
if we were at 22% which would include
the libertines trips as well then it
would be ever so slightly higher and but
that's obviously spread across the whole
hour you know they don't all come at
once so that level of increase is not
something that we would consider
problematic and and I also think we need
to be careful that we're not making the
business decision for trigger Mills here
this is a planning decision based on
whether there is a planning reason for
us to approve or refuse a scheme and so
far in light of the absence of concerns
from Devon County Council yeah I'm not
sure that there is thank you thank you
right hook thank you I do have concerns
on a date and the customer and staff
survey that was just referred to I think
also it's several years ago also
concerned that the route choice options
map and this reassigning of trips isn't
realistic of current travel and setting
up future travel in particular taking
into account the development at Halton
bantam which as some counselor patches
pointed out this staple Hill Road will
be a very short the shortest route by
distance maybe not by time that's
questionable
to this new entrance into tregos so all
of those factors do do concern me I'm
also concerned about the increase in
traffic through Dickinson village so
although most of that road pickings and
Road I would say
the problem I didn't think I'm
necessarily concerned about the junction
of staple Hill Road with pickings and
Road almost of Dickenson Road but the
victory of the village I would be
concerned about and also most concerned
about staple Hill Road which is a
extremely narrow lane I mean I agree
with someone else here that said I
regularly travel to work from bridges
83-82 is my trip to work and the drum
bridge is upgrade was transformational
in terms of reducing the problems that
drum bridge is roundabouts so it's
interesting to hear that comment that
locals don't feel drawn bridges is
congested because certainly on my trips
to work drum bridges is not congested
let's hope we don't get to the point
where it is congested again because you
know ever they did that work so and that
should be the proper route into Tragos
and with our a380 to improvements which
will be coming forward soon and taking
place at the moment that is the prime
and sensible route by which vehicles
should access trigger mills and we
should be part of our role is ensuring
that traffic that is generated by
development is guided to the roads that
are most appropriate and those are the
a38 as has been mentioned not picking
some Road drum bridges and the a380 -
those are the roads that we should be
guiding traffic to you know I have to
accept that most visitors that are going
to traders are going to approaches bulky
goods and they're not going to carry
them on the back of the bicycle so I've
taken my climate change off temporarily
and accepted that people visit tregos by
car and that should be by name roads and
drawbridges roundabouts I say my
particular concern is stable Hill Road
it is a route I've I've used it
frequently as a cycling route to avoid
the current a380 - it's the nice cut
through which you can use it is very
narrow it wouldn't I think take much of
an increasing in traffic at all and is
used by walkers and horse riders as well
so and it does have a problem with
flooding which I experience so it's not
not a route that we want to encourage
more traffic on to and I was just
thinking of Alton Road that some of you
will know where as the development came
forward at Houghton Barton there was
there is a proposal and will be bogs
that are put into Houghton Lane roof
Bank Road to stop traffic accessing that
as a through route now that potentially
is something that we could do that
staple Hill Road I would like to think
it's not part of this proposal but
certainly that would be something that
would alleviate that problem if someone
stapled Hill Road we could put bond so
that it's not a through Road but as it
is that's not the proposal on the table
I I'm you know I do have great concerns
about this one but you know I fully
accept that we don't have the backing of
Durham County which makes it very very
very difficult to make it to make a
refusal decision so you know but I do
have concerns thank you right councillor
Wrigley next ways Thank You Jer well
council MacGregor and councillor Hook
have to have touched on a number of the
points I'd like to make we're being
asked to believe two impossible things
or two contradictory things
well first of all being asked to believe
that the traffic on this new route will
be negligible will be unimportant when
you won't even notice the distant
difference secondly we're being asked to
believe that the traffic on this route
will be critical to the importance to
the livelihood of trago mills both
things cannot be true they're either
expecting a significant traffic flow on
this route or it's not going to be
commercially viable for them to do it so
I think we can actually look at that and
take the traffic numbers as councilor
patch has demonstrated with a pinch of
salt now this is a single lane road a
single lane road that's what we're
talking about putting all this extra
traffic going in trago mills people take
their cars to get their bulky goods as
councillor hook was saying down the
single lane road it's not suitable the
suitable place is the improved a38 - as
councillor Hooke was describing
the key thing that I think we can work
with in the report it is in 3.08 they
have they have raised no objections
they've concluded the proposal county
highways or concluded the proposal will
have no severe impact on the operation
of the strategic or local highway
networks what they haven't said is that
there will be an impact on the local
environment there there will be an
impact on this country lane one way lane
you look at it's not even made up it's
got that horrible sort of gritty
gravelly stuff on it that really is
annoying and gets in your brakes if
you've got old cars it's not a suitable
road to support a significant amount of
traffic going into trago mills it's not
a significant amount of traffic is not
necessary certainly our type like to
take a little bit of issue with the idea
of 120 journeys per hour coming very
nicely one every 30 seconds I did spend
a certain amount of my career doing a
mathematical mathematical modeling of of
networks including queueing theories and
it's not about taking a total number and
spreading it out evenly over time it's
about looking at how the queues and the
nodes and the server's actually take
that traffic if you're putting extra
traffic into that area you need to model
it see what the queues are going to be
like don't think of it as one car every
30 set every 30 seconds they are going
to come in bunches altogether you're
going to get 10 cars at once queuing up
causing problems or you're going to get
one car zipping through oh look there's
no queue here today it's not going to be
a good scene we're gonna see more
accidents and I find it once again very
very disappointing that highways will
only look at a serious accident where
somebody is killed to consider that a
road may be dangerous I am not prepared
to vote for something that has the
potential for killing people for
commercial gain
on this basis
and that's okay thank you can I just
clarify one point the the single main
bit that you referred to that isn't the
actual access to the site that's being
suggested it's a long road that's wide
enough
up to the entrance gate however that
single lane that you're referring to in
which councilor that referred to as
possibly she might have thought to be
boarded
he's a route that currently could be
used by people coming from the sort of
Newton Abbot direction but it doesn't
form part of the traffic assessment
because it is it is assumed that those
people will be coming through picking
Tyndall so the route to the site is to
carriageways up to the gate but there is
this other single Lane I just wanted to
clarify for any other members that
weren't familiar with the location but I
got councillor Bullivant please I'm
sorry boss did you want to come in on
that point before I said whatever it was
thank you very much wanted to clarify a
point about the reference to a severe
impact that County highways have used
and that that phraseology is lifted
directly from the National planning
policy framework and so the text in that
document says development should only be
refused on highway grounds if there
would be an unacceptable impact on
highway safety or the residual
cumulative impact on the highway network
would be severe so County are saying
that there is no highway capacity reason
for refusal because the impact on the
road network would not be severe so that
that's lifted directly from government
guidance which is why they use that
language and thank you all right cancer
Bullivant
thank you the point I want you to make
was that my ward obviously compasses
part of these staple purse wrote as it
gets engineered now that at the weekend
I took the trouble to drive the route
got to see the location and see where
this entrance was proposed to be put
driving from Newton Abbot knowing that
there's going to be a wide Boulevard
parallel to staple this road to trago
mills makes me believe that there will
be very little traffic ever wishing to
use the back row other people and their
bicycles because is it very narrow it is
a very pretty back row and when you get
to the point in the road where the
entrance would be the road is already
opened up to two lane width I actually
took the trouble to go and step across
the road see how wide he was then go
across to the other entrance and that
road there is at least as wide is the
other entrance so the traffic that's
projected to come down the old a 38 go
straight into the exit comes 200 yards
about a hundred meters of road that's it
unfortunately map doesn't show it
clearly like that it's cut off in doing
that it comes past a church building
which has wet set well back off the road
and some holiday cottages the very other
houses that the house is in staple this
road of tend to be further down the
gonna country lane on that basis I don't
believe there's going to be an impact
there listing the problems on the a
three eight three Jong sheet with a
baking turn road I mean at junctions
over three miles away I don't think it's
a valid point to raised against this
application my grandchildren also go to
Blackpool school so obviously I have an
interest in making sure that whatever is
done as this an impact or doesn't have
an impact on their safety and looking at
so what is proposed as I've got no doubt
at all there will be absolute minimal
impact on a safety for any other
children that are going to that school
recognizing the cars do park around the
corner but at times when this traffic
will ceased or reduced greatly
I'm also interesting the fact that this
route will open up the shorter route
into who were trago mills which will
reduce traffic journeys by about a
hundred that by about a mile and a half
so people that instead of having to go
down the old a38 go around from bridges
then come back up into trago mills so
there's a significant saving in fuel and
therefore we're helping the environment
if you open this allow this access to
open I think if you go and have a look
at the location if you see what's
actually planned if you see the current
width of the road and the fact it's got
little or no impact on any residences of
quality kotti is next to it then I don't
believe there is a justifiable planning
reason given that the Consol T's have
suggested that they're happy with the
designs I cannot see a justifiable
planning reason for turning this
application down thank you thank you
councillor Patrick thank you chairman
I've chosen to support to a councillor
patches proposal for refusal because I'm
looking at a photograph that he sent
last night of the proposed Junction
stable Hill Road and Libertines beacon
tomorrow and there are double lines on
the main road and a sharp bend in the
distance if this was going to be a
completely new development I thought I
would have thought that highways would
have perhaps wanted to have around about
him circuit there so their traffic is
going to slow down and would have to
give way to cars wanting to go in
different directions I mean I think
looking at the picture it's potentially
an accident black spot looking at the
the highways safety which is 3.16 so the
highways are not suggesting around about
they're suggesting that there's a
visibility splice in both directions are
acceptable acceptable and they feel that
the that the speeds driven a long staple
who
rohde are likely not to exceed 37 miles
an hour so they're likely not to exceed
37 miles an hour but does that mean that
they're likely to exceed 30 37 miles an
hour I mean I think there should be
speed restrictions put on the road if
this does go ahead but I I'm still not
comfortable with it thank you thank you
can counsel regret you indicate you wish
to come back
thank you again chair just just to come
back to the sustainable development
element and Ross is response about the
the future of the business the the S one
a and s one are quite clear as well in
terms of the the economic benefit if
it's just to really route traffic for
convenience sake then the question would
be whether it be any any economic
benefit there at all and it does it just
say that the the economic environment
but environmental benefits etcetera
should outweigh any any problems that
would be generated from that the big
problem that we have is we're using
figures that as councillor patches
pointed out probably a little bit out of
date
we've got highways saying well there's
nothing really gonna be an impact for us
because it takes you know it takes a
little bit traffic off earlier if it's
coming off of Highways England land and
and Devon highway saying well it doesn't
really increase the volumes but it you
know here's is no accent here so it's
difficult to see that there is actually
a benefit that outweighs the the impact
for pedestrians cyclists uses the bit
that the road as it stands at the moment
so I would say that I think the impact
is too great on the the risk to health
and safety for pedestrians and cyclists
and horse riders using staple Hill Road
and vikatan Lane areas for the potential
increase in traffic which whilst we have
got a guesstimate from planning we don't
know what the actual outcome will be
after the road is opened or developed if
it goes ahead thank you thank you
councillor patch indicating to speak
again now comes up at you moved refusal
for the highways reasons clearly it's
contrary to the offers of recommendation
so we'll need to have some sort of
specific detail
for your proposal and why it would be
why are we going you would be going
contrary to officer recommendation Kappa
- Thank You chair I would like to bring
this back to consideration of - accident
black spots an existing accident black
spot on the junction of the a 383 and
the picking tonneau hood and a potential
accident black spot on the junction of
the Binghamton Road and the right-hand
turn into staple Hill Road now the road
traffic the traffic and highway
assessment assesses the likelihood of
queuing on a blind bend in both of those
potential black small acts actual and
potential black spots on outdated
baseline data and on quite frankly
dubious assumptions about reassignment
of traffic those calculations are the
basis of asserting that this would be a
safe development I pointed out and in
quite some detail in the documents of
center councillors the questioning
nature of these calculations it's been
it's been raising you've just raised it
yourself that the highways the local
authority have not raised an objection
now I've actually received confirmation
they have not scrutinized these two
calculations they've not scrutinized
these proposals at any great depth at
all I would just point out that
government guidance suggests that
transport assessments are thorough
assessments of the transport
implications of development there has
been no thorough assessment other than
that which I've attempted in documents
I've sent to the counselors now I would
like to paint the picture of a potential
judicial review if this application were
granted I believe there would be a case
based on legitimate expectation that the
highways or authority would scrutinize
the applicants traffic and highways
assessment which has not been done and
also on the legitimate expectation that
local planning authority ie us by the
officers or this committee would
scrutinize reports submitted as evidence
in support of an
location so to that end if this
application were granted and either the
parish council or local applicant remind
it to look at a case with judicial
review I would be happy to work with
them on that but I'd hope it wouldn't
get to that stage I would draw attention
back again to an existing accident black
spot a potential accident black spot on
blind bends where the case for them not
not being worsened is based on faulty
calculations that have not been
scrutinized thank you okay I think we
understand those points did you wish to
add anything about the single
carriageway of stapler Hill Road to your
yeah I am in no doubt that would be
developed as a rat run a lot of traffic
from reports from Bradley Ward the bull
events Ward would take that route they
will see it as a direct route to get in
and out of Trager Mills okay I think
Paul you indicated raising your hand
then Poole yes sir thank you um I I try
not to interject too often so that's not
my role but I think I it would be remiss
of me not to raise significant concerns
as to what counsel patches just
indicated of his likely intention
depending on the outcome of of any
voting respect of this there were issues
raised in respect of the capacity in
which councilor patch was making his
submissions I appreciate states that he
was acting as board member but there has
to be a clear distinction between the
role and written representing the views
and as a ward member and that of the
district overhaul which is what the
Planning Committee is there to decide it
is also there to decide on the planning
merit an application on planning merit
to indicate given the circumstances of
council patch to indicate that he would
openly support any judicial review
against the decision of the council in
my mind puts him in a very very
difficult situation in respect to taking
part further in these proceedings
okay thank you my soul counts the patch
you heard what was just said so what you
have just said might be deemed to have
put you in a case of being a
pre-determined in your view on this by
virtue of what you're saying you might
do in the event of the vote not being in
me the way that you have moved your
proposal so now I come back on that
chair yes you will I mean you need to
you need to have reflected on that and
come to the zeros and the decision is
yours
you've heard the advice yeah well I
don't consider a case of
predetermination bait based on the
discussion that we've had I'm raising
that as a possibility I don't see that
as predetermined I didn't come into the
meeting with an intention of backing a
judicial review I've got no idea in case
it if if any local residents would be
wanted to raise one but my concern is
that if a judicial review were launched
then it would put this Authority in a
very different position with regards to
this application given the concerns I've
raised that I do not believe these
calculations on road traffic safety have
been properly scrutinized and I can see
the potential impacts of that in terms
of serious road accidents near to a
school and an existing accident black
spot as well thank you okay we
understand I think nobody else is
indicated to speak I take it the
officers have nothing to say
I won't keep you long
it's just my parish is obviously
adjacent to listen to parents and on the
weekend I did drive through up through
the middle of trago mills through the
main entrance and right up through to
the back and then I went around the
beakington end and that's very stable
Hill as I passed the proposed
entrance to the turning into travel
Mills off staple Hill and entered the
narrow so to speak
I met another lady in a Range Rover and
there was just nothing she traversed
about 200 yards back to Langley for me
that is the kind of single lying Lane
that we're looking at here and if
they've been washed riders and cyclists
as well there it would have been a
pretty mess but I think given that that
leg is so narrow and I haven't driven it
for a long time and I wouldn't want to
very often but I can understand that
people will use it as a wrap run to get
into travel mills and I think it's you
know it's a another accident waiting to
happen
and also knowing that there's been two
accidents within the last week on the
pond the junction that staple Hill and
making to Rome it's it's quite
frightening really thank you thank you
right so we'll go to the vote now please
it's for refusal the motion is for
refusal on the highways reasons about
line by account to the patch so I think
everyone's clear on that so if I could
ask Chris please to go through with the
vote so it's my funeral so if you want
your views on you stay for the future
yes okay could you could Chris for not
take a nice place Paul yep sorry chair
just for the sake of transparency could
council the patch just clarify
particularly what the reasons for
refusal are specifically firstly Tecla
ask you this is speaking attends the
planning committee okay thank you chair
or taking me to this policy so oldest
policy s1 sustainable development
criteria and at EDC local plan policy
which quotes the proposals will be
required to perform well against the
in criteria B road safety and congestion
sustainable me sorry hello hello hello
can you hear me I can hear you cancel a
patch I can't hear you I think I came
for a second
the Germans doesn't appear is screen
appears a lot should we give them a
minute to come back yeah see if he tries
to rejoin the meeting you're back Mike
no you're muted mic we can see Mike B
you're muted at the man in you unmute
Amer Chris yeah Chris yep there we go
I'm sorry screen frozen just as the
counselor patch started to speak so I
don't know what happened there so
counselor patch I missed what you had to
say but I I'm afraid given that I won't
then be able to vote if I wasn't in the
whole meeting I'm gonna have to ask you
to repeat it please that's okay I
haven't got very far before we'd realize
that your screen is frozen anyway chair
okay so you are actually miss anything I
don't think you would be able to vote
because thought exactly where I started
before yeah
the TBC local plan policy s1 sustainable
development development criteria
the proposed development of sorry
subject to other development plan
policies which may determine the
suitability of the location for the
proposed development and providing a
specific road of overriding requirements
in a particular case proposals will be
required to perform we're held against
the following criteria road safety and
congestion I could quote s9 sustainable
transport policy s 22.2 side policy W e
11 green infrastructure policy I could
go back to NP PPF paragraph 10 but I
honestly think the the first points are
quoted would be adequate thank you
okay my understanding music my
understanding that the reason for
refusal is that it's contrary to policy
at the reasons that counsel patches set
out yeah okay in something a chair well
it's I think it the detail of the actual
junctions and the road is just outlined
so I don't think there's any other
policy thing to ride the patsies
proposing I was going to add at the s22
specifically H portion age track the
impact caused by the change in travel
patterns is a reason for refusal adding
to councillor Patty's point specific
detail well I have to ask very very
happy to accept that and thank Council
over on the grinder for that
interjection right so if we could go to
the vote then please the motion is for
refusal so if you are for refusing your
vote for clearly if you think it should
be approved you'll be voting against
okay Chris can we go through taken
recorded vote please
okay councillor bradford cancelable
event begins
so Clarence against how's the cold cloth
all counselor Cox or counselor Hayes Oh
counselor hook that was a Jeffrey
counselor shank Kealing sorry against
counselor Kerswell muted thanks
never on your music sorry full Thanks
Chancellor McGregor boy counselor Nutley
or counselor Nuttall or counselor Parker
or counts the patch or counselor Patrick
or counselor vertically Oh counselor
Hanes against and counselor Goodman
Bradbury against okay so that's 13 in
favor and six against so that means that
that motion is current so the mission is
refused for the reasons that have been
outlined right if we could move on then
to the final application today
sincere apologies for interrupting you
would it be possible to have a two
minute comfort break please we've been
two hours now would that be acceptable
there's two minutes yes if members
quickly need to pop out we'll get the
public speakers into the meeting and
then I'll need to confirm that
everyone's back before we start so we
need to look on the screen okay do that
[Music]
before you leave Chris did you want to
sorry the speaker yeah it's just the one
for this application in the one
Supporter where the YouTube is
continuing during this
yes okay okay so yes it's just the one
Supporter coming in for this application
and no objectors and I think we'll have
to do a roll call all again one set once
we do create so
[Music]
you
you
you
[Music]
hi Steven
just making sure that you know whether
you're in the meeting now hello yeah
thank you wait until you're ready
Thanks all right okay when we go through
the roll call again to the please Chris
okay um counselor Bradford present
counsel Bullivant present also Clarence
present that's the cold cloth cancer
cold cloth and think she's back yet okay
cancer coxed prison Elsa Goodman
Bradbury present counselor Haynes
present counselor Hayes also hook house
the Jeffrey the key even close well
present counsel McGregor resident
counselor Nutley also not all prison
how's the Parker present counsel pouch
present also path work counselor Wrigley
present and it counts the cold cloth
again
yes present thank you okay right so
everyone's back and we've got the public
speaker and is present in the meeting
Chris I understand yes yes right in
which case then if we move on can I ask
Kelly pleased to introduce the item
that's Kelly grill should be with us
Thank You chairman I will just share my
screen Roz would you mind end in
PowerPoint out please
apologies took a while to to open up
there can you can everybody see that
that screen I can see the screen with
the list of files
hopefully okay I'm gonna start again I'm
gonna try that one again apologies there
with me okay as I can see something now
except it's coming up as half the screen
on the wrong half I really got the audio
that's it better I'm sorry
right now thank you our apologies that
my own screen sharing haven't been
enabled so I'm not able to share it so
the applications outline planning
permission for up to 135 dwellings
including access and the relevant public
open space landscaping and Associated
works and infrastructure so here's the
larger scale site context we can see
that these site is located to the north
of it another is on the north side of
Norfolk Tracy Road and to the west of
Exeter Road both of these have 60 mile
per hour limits the site is located to
the also to the north of the site you
can gain access to teen Grace and King
Satan and we can see to the southeast is
the hospital and then around the site we
can see the Blachford brook which goes
through the site and then around its
edges thank you us so this is the
specific site which is approximately
7.42 hectares of grasp restoral fields
the site is bordered by trees and
hedgerows of varying quality and
completeness works have currently
commenced on the south side of the site
as part of the 88 - road widening screen
and scheme and I've got some photos of
that later
we can see around the site there are
just a handful of residential properties
so we've got Sanford only farm to the
east
we've got Barry Knowles which borders a
site to the south and then we've got
Blackford farm house in black red barn
which we can see here which mothers are
pointing to thank you and this isn't an
up-to-date aerial image but it was the
most up-to-date I can find so we can see
the n/a to allocation which is is quite
well-developed right now we can see from
this aerial view it does show how much
screening and hedgerow is currently
around the site and we can just see
where the residential properties set
around where the site is located and you
can also see where the built form is so
how close the site is to existing belt
development this is a five which just
shows the nearby allocation so we can
see the na2
is opposite the site and importantly the
brown edging around the energy to our
application is the settlement limits for
you and other and it's for these reasons
when we refer to this site in the
officer report we talked about it being
a sustainable location for development
thank you us so we refer to the road
widening works already that are
currently taking place the specific
phase adjacent to the application site
is shown in this slide so the road works
presently taking place to be marked with
an arrow we can see the site the north
of this and then the area to the east
and coke
Oh
much more bits made Kelly
others might mean the same uncanny very
well then large park area I'm happy to
give you again so the the slide here is
the an approved slide for the Devon
County Council applications for the road
widening works and this slide rates
speaks of the phase adjacent to the
application site so the blue arrow below
where it says roadworks presently taking
place these are currently taking place
and then to the yes the right hands
upper corner of the screen
I identify the jetty Marsh to connection
which is the area of land owned by the
applicant which forms part of the
planning game package that comes forward
with this planning application thank you
and these are just some photos that I
took on site yesterday just so members
could see where they presently are and
how about is progressing in relation to
the application site so in the distance
beyond the tree you can see an earth
mound and that's where very noses beyond
that so you can see some roof lines and
beyond that into the application site
and these are just some photos to give
members an idea of the Exeter Road and
where the access will be coming from so
the property you'll even see on the
right hand side is Sanford Ollie farm
and the access would come out a point
for you know forward of this building
but opposite on the opposite side of the
road and this again is from Exeter Road
just looking through the gaps down
towards Bobby take Tracy Road so you get
an idea of where hedgerows are alongside
the road and and where it is in the
distance from Exeter road again looking
south down xf2 Road now past Sandford
Ollie farm and the access will come out
beyond the buildings on the right-hand
side where you see the hedging so within
the report we talked about how
an earlier proposal was to provide a
roundabout and then in discussions with
Devon County Council as well as our
conservation officer it was considered
that a t-junction would result in less
impact on heritage assets but be less
intrusive on this residential property
as well as less hedgerow removal
[ __ ] going down Extro towards baffi
tracy road we can see where the nae -
white heeled development is in the
distance and the site would sit within
this built context again this just is
shows where we come out on the junction
on to Bobby Tracey Road so we talked
about this in outline Planning
Commission for up to 135 dwellings and
includes access this is an indicative
plan provided by the applicant to give
us an idea of how the development might
come forward so the cream and gray areas
at the south side of site are where we
expect to be built development to come
forward and if this is also outside of
flood zone two and three and the
development is presenting 30% affordable
housing as well as 20% custom build
which is above our policy of requirement
we can see where the site access is so
where we were looking at the photos
previously we can see it comes forward
of Sanford oli farm and again we can see
some site linkages within the site which
go north heading towards keen grace to
provide some accessible links in that
direction and then the rear part the
fight would compose of public open space
and then we'd have quite significant
landscaping ecological enhancements
coming forward as part of this
application so we've we've discussed
some of the planning benefits previously
that this plan which is also in the
agenda just highlight the area of land
that would be transferred as part of the
approval of this application so it would
help to facilitate the delivery of the
jetty - link which is shown below and
you can also see going north of
strategic cycleways proof delivered and
connect this national cycle 28 think
and these are just some plans showing
the junction improvements that would
take place but I think they've taken
place with whitehill anyway
prior to - this is how this fight would
be access until the Devon County Council
roundabout is implemented these are just
some detailed drawings showing where the
access will come in so again we can see
where Sanford all these farmers and we
can see that the access comes in south
of that
you
a previously discussed the site does
part the site is within flood zone too
and flood zone three the housing in the
built development has been contained
outside a flood zone two and three but
the access serving the site does cross
over the flood zone and as a result an
emergency access have been provided and
that's shown on the next slide so this
is the emergency feature access which
would be used an extreme flood event and
as I've said on the slide officers and
the TDC emergency planner have reviewed
the access details as well as the
Environment Agency and we're satisfied
that this pouch is acceptable
so as longer-term as part of the
different county council approved road
widening works there will be sustainable
links providers so these are highlighted
in yet yellow and how connections
between the very laws proposed
development and the approved ECC works
would be achieved so we can see here at
the roundabout when it's put in how
connections could be provided and the
next slide shows further links so again
we can see the highlighted route in
yellow how residents of the berry normal
development could access access like
pedestrian and cycle links through the
improvements that are coming forward
early today the next slide sorry I think
it was as I talked about later in the
report at this stage we've tried to take
into account the phasing and time in all
feed Evan came council works and to show
this site remain sustainable we've
proposed a missive class so we can see
it with the green dots and the
applicants also indicated a pass that
could be provided with orange dots on
the plan on the right hand side and this
would be by Mill Street Road which the
applicant owns recommendation currently
includes a condition for
the interim link to be provided however
it's officer recommendation that we
revise this condition to require a state
stainable access strategy to be provided
and including a timetable for
implementation and this is just because
we don't know we're definitely council
will be with the road widening scheme at
the time reserved matters is made who
allows us to take a view on what links
are necessary at the time they reserve
matter application is made and the
recommendation has been changed to
reflect this condition Thank You Robin
this is just to indicate how sustainable
the like this fight presently is in
terms of busts of links and how the
committed path just shown would leak
into this and enable future residents of
the Maryknolls development to access bus
services thank you
again we've sought
hello jimy can you hear me okay I can
hear you clearly
okey thank yous my wishes first I can
thank you yes so these we've shown these
previously but these are just some of
the cycle linkages offered by the
applicant as part of the application
they would deliver these to make telly
can we just wait until Mike gets back
okay thank you
Chris can it-it's film livin here can I
suggest that we formally suspend the
meeting until Mike gets back just so
that there isn't a possibility being
excluded from the okay okay just check
mind are you happy with that absolutely
I think that's a good idea
okay can I suggest we suspend the
meeting for five minutes we just
hopefully might we'll be back in so it's
Sarah so away hopefully Michael be back
in very shortly if there's a major issue
then obviously we'll have to reach our
ester meeting hopefully it might be more
than a couple of minutes if I suspend
them in meeting and take it down off of
youtube I think the vice-chairman can
make that decision and Sarah I think the
buyer should may that concision yeah is
he still is Mike still trying to log in
at the moment with minutes yeah if we
give it a few more minutes as a
suspension and and then if it goes
longer than that then we might need to
well it might be me carries on and
someone send him a message or call him
[Music]
Chris and Sarah kill Belinda gay I think
because we've had this happen a couple
of times now we we require or we'll need
a formal process in the event of a
chairman or an aunt or a vice chairman
being prevented from taking part in the
meeting what procedures to follow so
it's a formal structure
I think if Sarah can't get ahold of him
we'll carry on with Councilman Bradbury
as the chair
you
[Music]
oh there's Paul would add legal adviser
just for councillor Bullivant we'll take
that on board and we'll then we'll
arrange such measures to be put in place
in the event it happens again I don't
really like getting in he will try but
mostly what better take part in voting
but if Linda give him a break Karen
Karen changes yeah that's fine well
we're midway through so if you'd like to
carry on with the presentation that'd be
great he can I dunno and sorry ass about
hiatus can I just check that you can see
the screen again with the cycle linkage
plan on it yes yes thank you yes it's
all back yeah so this is just a more
detailed image of some of the cycle in
the images shown on the previous flight
plan and these are just some images that
have been pulled out of the applicants
landscape visual impact assessment to
show we can see very Knowles from Exeter
Road here to show the visibility of the
scheme and the next slide Thank You Roz
shows the site from hi week and then the
dotted line is the baseline position
that they looked at in terms of where
the development could be seen from and
the landscape visual impact assessment
and also the addendum to it was looked
at very carefully by the council's
heritage team and we also considered
what type of development could come
forward to make sure so the landscape
impact both in terms of close-up views
and long term views from heritage assets
wouldn't be harmful and on the next
slide we the heritage team of brought
forward a parameter plan and a design
code which they fear will make sure that
a very high quality development comes
forward that would be able to respect
some of the heritage assets and the
more sensitive landscapes around the
site so we can see the the coding for
health type a in red house type B in
blue and then there's the next slide
will show some of the details that could
come forward so we specify things like
the frontage materials the block
characters how the public space might
come forward and the landscaping and
taking this into account we think we've
got assurances that a high development
will come forward when reserve matters
is committed and then just finally some
update so there were a few typos in the
officer report so in the recommended
conditions section I refer to a food
warning and evacuation plan which should
have read a flood warning and evacuation
plan and the second bullet in paragraph
five point ten the line is called out
refers to agree to building
approximately 150 meters away that that
isn't relevant and it doesn't refer to
any building and the other update is
that as I've mentioned previously we've
suggested that the previously
recommended condition for the interim
cycle and pedestrian link to come
forward is revised into requesting a
sustainable access strategy to come
forward including timescales for
implementation and that allows the local
authority to take a view on what is
required to make sure this that site is
sustainable and safe and accessible at
the time reserve matters is made when we
know more about where Devon County
Council have got with the rest of the
road widening development and key loss
and therefore we there's an officer
recommendation to approve outline
planning permission including the
details access subject to the terms of
the 106 set out below which we say
includes 30 percent affordable housing
20 percent custom build and also very
significantly the delivery of the land
to help facilitate the important jetty
marsh
to roadworks we've also made a
recommendation that the details for the
formal
we move from being a condition and come
into the legal agreement just to give us
a different way to manage that detail
coming forward and also subject to the
following conditions which will bring
forward the ecology and the landscape
and the access details the drainage that
we sow are acceptable in the report
thank you I think this one more
sidewalls and again after out the update
sheets and members we did recommend add
additional condition rate relating to
local food production to be incorporated
into a landscape condition as well as an
additional condition relate to
electrical vehicle charging points thank
you okay thank you Kelly what the
situation is with his back okay
obviously I won't because I missed some
of the presentation so then you want to
carry on because public speaking or not
no we haven't
it just had the finish of the actual
display I mean I don't know what the
convention is as you've got the list of
the public speakers it's probably better
for you Mike I mean whether this is very
a problem that's gonna keep coming back
to wait and see so you can see me
disappear Lynn please take over yeah
absolutely right okay so it's public
speaker next then I think it's I've got
Stephen Fisher is it the speaker place
that's right yes thank you thank you
members didn't you hear me yes yes great
okay
well I'll try I'll try and be brief and
this application by Sibelius stems from
a long association with the council and
with Devon County Council is about
enabling the live delivery of key
infrastructure in the form of the jetty
marsh link
he's been carefully considered and
rigorously tested by officers as you
know a belter an industrial mineral
business and their activities in Devon
are focused on bull clay not houses
however we've worked with the councils
over many years in delivering key
infrastructure projects in the past
including key parts of the state rail
permanent and permissive parts and
cycleways and extensions the stove part
poetry trail nature conservation
management and they're actively working
currently with officers to identify
opportunities for infrastructure that
underpin the garden community concept
including a zero and low-carbon energy
through this joint working companies
also helped deliver housing at new cross
and bring full with the king state in
school whilst this application is about
helping to deliver the a380 to junction
and jetty marsh link and the associated
cycle of pedestrian links as quickly as
possible any profits from the housing
developments are more than offset by
sepulchers investment locally in the
core industrial playing business
Sibella are investing millions currently
in new industrial plants and
infrastructure to support the continued
contribution to the local economy the
pedestrian and cycle connections to the
calls were in stable trail jetty Marsh
link our local plan commitments they're
relevant and directly related to the
housing proposed in this application and
they meet the statutory tests Sabella is
committed to helping deliver the council
social priorities also in terms of the
30 percent portable homes including
rented and shared ownership as well as
20 percent customer self-build homes
which we hope will enable local people
to deliver their their vision of a new
home a commitment that's significantly
above policy requirements the master
plan ensures that housing is delivered
in areas free from flood risk which
benefit from a level of green
infrastructure but also is significantly
over the council standards there's safe
and secure access it's been subject to
rigorous testing through the application
protest process and enhances
biodiversity including bat fly ways it's
endorsed by your advisers and natural
England while the application
facilitates the early construction of
the jetty wash link and the pedestrian
and cycle connections we're happy to
work with officers to provide the
sustainable
link in the shorts and if for whatever
reason that the jetty marshalling
doesn't commence soon for all of these
reasons therefore Sibel KO would commend
the application to you and hope that you
share the positive vision that it
represents thank you right thank you so
we move on to board members have got
councillor Bullivant please thank you at
the very early stage of this application
I must compliment the officers who saw
the opinions of ward members as to what
sort of development framework should
take place on this site which is just
outside the in a to allocation and after
a series of discussions we were able to
suggest things that we assess will
prefer to see on any development in this
area particularly as it goes along way
towards delivering that much-needed link
or improvement to the a38 to provided
the things on the ecology the the
natural things that we see on all of our
other developments took place we wanted
to ensure that those came forward as
part of the proposals we also identify
that we wanted to see some means of
people on this area which is within
walking distance of the town centre in
the hospital having access from day one
by cycle or footpath to be able to get
into the town and I'm pleased to see in
their application that that is covered
we also expressed concerns about the
views of high week what you didn't see
from the photographs that Kelly showed
was actually the slopes of the roads and
the quite steep hills involved so you
want to make sure that the views of
people approaching high week and the
historic context of high week were
respected I'm pleased to see that the
designs were altered to minimise impact
on that on that view we also looked at
the impact of the flooding
that we see potentially happening in 50
to 100 years time and what is no comfort
it's a fact that this area where the
housing is proposed will not be flooded
when the hospital is flooded or the town
of Newton avenues flooded so it's above
it is above the floodplain so flooding
won't be an issue and the water
retention on-site to release water into
the floodplain will meet the 90%
requirement of being no higher than 90
percent of the current level so from a
flood point of view the counselors will
Bradley were happy that this application
meets those requirements the provision
of the footpath being available from day
one before any houses occupied is
essential we we saw the problems with
the adjacent EMA to development that
footpath which goes through the stretch
of road at the top of the firm the
current made 3/8 to like by Churchill's
roundabout the footpath is inadequate
and by making sure that this footpath
becomes accessible from day one helps
alleviate some of the problems for there
but it also makes the people in this
development able to walk and slightly
into town so on the basis of all of
those things and the information that we
have in front of us having been through
it in detail I'm happy to recommend that
this application is approved as set out
and move there as a year as I said thank
you I lose that secondly there's Chris
towns I'd like to sing then I think as
amended outlined by Kelly and a bit of
the presentation I called at the end
underneath correct yeah thank you
right anyone else wish to speak Jackie
used the blue hand but I saw your hand
go up because you're on my screen yes I
think Mike maybe needs to do host again
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
the decisions that we need to apply to
this in one sense I guess we could just
simply leave it there and refuse
permission
we've done it before and I'm sure
someone could probably argue that in
this case but as has been said in this
lengthy and detailed committee report
there are many other highly relevant
factors for us to consider before making
a final decision and these are factors
that affect the well-being of our
residents in the future and the
sustainability of our town so firstly to
cover the whole topic of housing
development as we know the government
imposes a housing needs figure
that is currently 760 houses per year
that we need to enable to be built
within team bridge if we don't do this
there are various levels of penalties
that are imposed on us one of these
being the requirement to allocate even
more sites for housing there's no sign
that the government is changing that
requirement anytime soon in fact the
language coming out of government if
anything is moving in the other
direction
I think the phrases build build build
therefore we can safely assume that we
intend which need to carry on finding
further sites for housing development in
our district whether we want to or not
those sites will come forward in the
greater extra strategic plan and the
local plan part 2 we need to get away
from the notion that we aren't going to
require more sites not only do we have
the government demanding that we do this
but we even have given CPR e in their
assessment of housing need September
last year coming up with an annual needs
figure of 573 houses per annum for our
district this is ongoing year on year
therefore we do need to plan ahead as a
council it makes sense to ensure that
those sites that we are required to
provide are near existing facilities and
public transport so that we can
encourage use of sustainable travel this
largely means those sites need to be
near our existing towns this site is not
in our current local plan but was put
forward during the search for sites for
the local plan and is obviously still
available now so it's highly likely
therefore to be an allocated hives in
sight in our next local plan if national
housing demands are the same a refusal
today on the basis of this site not
being in the local plan really delays a
site coming forward rather than stop it
what we then need to look at is are
there any pluses to it coming forward
now rather than later and as the report
spells out there are indeed many very
good reasons to approve this site now
these are outlined in section 3 xx the
report look what that list to me is
facilitating the delivery of the jetty
Mart
link this is the road an accompanying
cycle foot way that will link the
current a38 to through to the hospital
site and west goals roundabout this link
is a crucial link not just for any
development here but for houses already
occupied at white Hill and future
development at any two white Hill and
anyone helps in Barton and when I say a
crucial link I'm referring predominantly
to its role as a sustainable travel link
the distance from Barry Knowles and
white Hill to the hospital in town
center is shorter than it is for much of
the existing housing in Newton Abbot and
on a completely flat route with the
Jesse Marsch link in place this and
Weitzel a very sustainable site we've
often heard at this committee and from
the public why can't we get the
infrastructure in first well we may not
have got jetty much to link road in
before the first part of white hill but
here we have an opportunity for city to
facilitate that to happen before the
rest of na-2 and anyone are built the
section 106 agreement requires Sibel co2
hand this land to Devon County at nil
cost and to assist as outlined with the
earthworks necessary the Iroko the road
already has planning position and as I
am told second honor this Follette
funding at this current moment in time a
more shovel ready scheme it is difficult
to imagine if permission is given here
today
in addition Sibel Cove offered to hand
over land to enable a link from the site
to the National Cycle way 28 otherwise
known as smooth away and through to
Kingston in the schools there this is
secured through planning condition other
benefits which are weren't going to are
outlined at 3:20 in the report the
communities from a sustainability
climate change point of view it's
important to remember in my view that
the biggest contributor to our carbon
emissions as a district is from
transport use second is the energy we
use in our homes and predominantly
within that and we heat our homes as
mentioned already not building houses is
not an option we are required to build
houses
the act of building houses itself is of
less significance to our overall carbon
emission than the lives of the residents
of those houses then lead what travel
needs they have and how they undertake
those journeys what we must do is ensure
we build houses where people can travel
to the facilities they need by foot
cycle and public transport with the
jetty March to link Road and cycle foot
way in place this is one of the most
sustainable sites I can think of on
those criteria we must also ensure that
the houses are built ideally in a carbon
neutral manner as you will know we've
recently updated our local plan carbon
calculator and this provides a more
rigorous framework to assess build
quality it is these standards that would
need to be adhered to by the developer
I've engaged more recently with this
application with Kelly than the officers
have dealt with it more recently and
with Helen beforehand and pushed on the
fine detail as as you've heard
councillor Bullivant as well I wanted to
thank Kelly in particular for ensuring
that the conditions we have in place are
the best we can have within the
constraints of the current planning
system and our current local plan and
those two last bits are quite important
because this is all within our current
planning system and our current local
plan and not to mention also our current
enforcement possibilities so you know we
don't live in a perfect world but I'm
happy that this is the best we can do
within the system we have at the moment
so there's an extensive list section 106
list and a list of planning conditions
covering affordable and custom built
house in biodiversity gain flooding
drainage carbon reduction and a whole
host of a host of other things the list
of benefits that this application brings
forwards for our residents and future
residents well beyond what we would be
likely to achieve if we refused this
application today and wait for it to
come forward through the Local Plan
process the proposal as a whole allows
for the delivery of other crucial
components of our local plan that are
required for a sustainable town I would
ask one thing that I have known
just in the recommendation two it says
that the drafting of the conditions the
full drafting of the conditions would be
delegated to the business manager and I
would like to add in that that ideally
would would be with in consultation with
both of Bradlee counselors counselor
relevant and myself and Rob Hayes as the
Bushell counselors if I could ask for
that and also I'd like to ask whether
the management of open and green spaces
which is currently a condition could be
added to the section 106 agreement to
tighten up that arrangement so I just
wanted to ask for those two changes but
I do understand to keep the contentious
nature of this decision but as
counselors on the Planning Committee we
we have an opportunity to take material
considerations into account alongside
the local plan in making our decisions
those material considerations do need to
be substantial for us to make a decision
that approves a housing site outside of
our local plan and in the vast majority
of cases we have refused such
applications but for me the balance as
I've described tips in favor of approval
of this application thank you um I just
check the proposer would he be happy to
take on those points that you said about
in consultation with the ward members is
also councillor Hawking is there's the
other Ward member for that I just wanted
to make the point yeah I just want to
make the point that yes there are two
gangsters for Bradley and I'm happy that
the Bradley Ward members are consulted
that's fine okay
and the other point was about in the 106
where I can kind of check with the
officer that that would be okay I have
no issues about that yes that the
recommendation is for all elements
relating to the play and the management
of it to be moved from a condition to
the 106 agreement Thank You Jennifer
okay thank you very for clarity just the
public open space as well as the play I
think Kelly we've got two conditions
down covering both of them
so it just will move both the play and
the open space into 186 I think that's a
concern a shorthand rather than a
disagreement on that all right so
Jackie's okay with that I've got some
other speakers can you please keep it
brief and not repeat any points that
have already been made sorry it was his
castle Clarence Hoover I'll be very
brief mr. Jim I think everything has
been said I purely wanted to thank Kelly
Braun he'll forget Fay negotiating what
she has and with Sibel co and coming up
with well I thought was extremely good
package that team breeze got out of this
development altogether absolutely
first-rate so congratulations from my
point of view to Kelly and I've said all
I need to say thank you Thank You
councillor McGregor Thank You chair I
just wanted to kind of perhaps summarize
what councillor has said she said that
would be too long but I think this is
it's a great opportunity I would like to
thanks in Belko particularly as well for
coming up with a which is going to have
significant impact on the health and
well-being and social housing and
affordable housing element of our plan
of all you know it's despite the fact
that the actual site is outside that and
specifically the consideration they've
given to green infrastructure and the
look and feel and protection of heritage
assets as well and I think and thank you
both also to the planning officers as
well for getting through particularly
thank you Qasr Patrick
comes from present Rick Thank You
chairman I'll be brief as well I
appreciate that
two thirds of this site is going to be
set aside for open green spaces and I
realize that this is an application for
for outline permission for up to 135
dwellings I mean are the officers
satisfied that the site that's going to
be built on is of adequate size for the
construction of up to 135 dwellings
which would include Rose Road whips of a
suitable width to accommodate two-way
traffic and sufficient off-road parking
for two cars per dwelling not including
garage space and also reasonable garden
space as well
thank you thank you carry a huge Kevin
yes we are satisfied that the space
available is sufficient for 135
dwellings and the associated
infrastructure I mean it is a
significant site and I think there's at
least three point five hectares I'd have
to get the exact figure out of the
agenda which will be developed on and
the plan the parameter plan and the
coding that you've seen that was drawn
up by our landscape officer within our
heritage team and they looked at those
factors when they put that coding
together Thank You counsel Bradford
Levin council event causing to sum up
councillor Bradford
thank you very much I do agree with
councillor hooks that yes we the
government says we have to build houses
but I believe that they have we don't
need to rip up the countryside we need
to be looking at other sites brand field
sites so that we're not hurting all the
beautiful green fields we have around us
we have declared a climate emergency we
have declared an environmental emergency
we've lost 50% of our wildlife and I
really couldn't vote for this thank you
Thank You councillor Bullivant
I just wanted to thank everybody who
they consideration and again think Kelly
Connell through an excellent job in
producing a very good detail before okay
thank you
that's it right okay so we've got the
motion before us that permission be
approved as set out with the revised
details from Kelly and her report and so
can I ask Chris to go through the Rings
yes so councillor Bradford against Kevin
Poole councillor Clarence or cancer coal
cloth comes the hook
councillor Geoff free or councillor
Keeling all comes to Carswell I'm
staying
Council McGregor councillor Nutley for
council stain councillor Parker for and
for perch against council Patrick or
councillor Wrigley abstain and counts of
a good man proper
so that's 12 in favor three against and
three abstentions and I didn't vote so
that's carried and I so therefore that
is approved permission is granted right
thank you we could move on then to the
final item on the agenda which is the
appeal decisions at item 10 to be noted
you see there's just one decision there
and that was the appeal was dismissed
okay
well that actually concludes the meeting
thank you all very much for your
attendance today sorry I left you
briefly I have to go and ask about my
route of the city needs needs to be
updated okay right might have a word up
the list please have any conversations
but feel free now to to depart and I'll
see you sometime in the near future
they're my new tubes still on I think I
will let you know when I stopped YouTube